So, I know this seems like a lot of information, and it is. But that's why you
have this PDF. Come back to it whenever you need to, it should really help.
Now, the last section of this lesson that we're going to go over is how you can
measure brain activity. I'm going to pass it to Susan to explain it to you.
&gt;&gt; Many of the advances in understanding a link between behavior and brain have
occurred in the last 20 years because of better techniques of measuring brain
activity. For example, how do we know that spatial ability is related to the
parietal area? Or that the frontal lobe is responsible for impulse control? How
do we know the hippocampus is associated with learning and memory?
Historically, we learned about the brain function through accidents. Such as we
saw with Phineas Gage. Since the 1940s we have been able to measure brain
activity. But it's really been since the 1990s that we've seen better
techniques that allow us to look at precise areas of the brain that are being
activated. This has been such a revolution that some people call it the
neuroscience revolution.